bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre cet
après-midi en séance
la poursuite de l'examen de la réforme
électorale annoncée par françois
hollande lors des états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale
hier soir après plus de huit heures de
combat marqué par de vifs échanges
le sénat a rejeté le scrutin paritaire
l'une des mesures phare du texte défendu
par manuel valls
ce mode d'élection décrit comme unique
au monde aurait dû permettre d'élire ont
ce scrutin majoritaire un binôme hommes
femmes par canton la droite a vilipendé
cette innovation parce qu'elle imposait
un redécoupage des cantons laissé à
l'entière discrétion du ministère de
l'intérieur et qui aurait entraîné la
réduction par deux du nombre de ces
cantons l'ump l'ump
pardon et la majorité des centristes ont
voté contre
les écologistes et les communistes eux
se sont abstenus et seul le ps et le rds
up ont voté pour ce projet est un
véritable camouflet pour le gouvernement
et la chambre des collectivités
territoriales qui est le sénat avec
notamment pour conséquence que
l'élaboration d'un nouveau mode de
scrutin pour les cantonales à la suite
de la suppression du conseiller
territorial mis en place par nicolas
sarkozy reviendra maintenant à
l'assemblée nationale le sénat a en
revanche adopté le principe d'un
renouvellement des conseillers généraux
tous les six ans au lieu d'un
renouvellement par moitié tous les trois
ans actuellement
je suis donc direction l'hémicycle pour
l'examen de cette réforme des élections
la séance est reprise par courrier en
date du 18 janvier 2013
monsieur le premier ministre a fait part
de sa décision de placer en application
de l'article l eau de 197 du code
électoral monsieur martial bourquin
sénateur du doubs en mission temporaire
auprès de monsieur pierre moscovici
ministre de l'économie et des finances
et de monsieur arnaud montebourg
ministre du redressement productif
cette mission portera sur l'ordre public
économique et les relations
interentreprises acte est donnée de
cette communication
nous reprenons la suite de la discussion
du projet de loi relatif à l'élection
des conseillers départementaux des
conseillers municipaux et des délégués
communautaires et modifiant le
calendrier électoral dans la discussion
des articles
nous sommes parvenus à l'amendement 352
au sein de l'article 16 bis je vous
rappelle donc que nous avons neuf
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune est tout d'abord donc
l'amendement 350 2 et le sous-amendement
358 présenté par le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci cher président juste pour préciser
que le gouvernement retire cet
amendement est dans la tente de la suite
des débats mais nous retirons cet
amendement en l'état merci monsieur le
ministre
alors nous en arrivons donc à
l'amendement 72e' les succès n'arrivons
l'amendement 72 rectifier je crois qu'il
n'est pas soutenu le 258 rectifier et
présentée par monsieur lézard
merci monsieur le président sur le mini
mes chers collègues qu'il s'agit
simplement par cet amendement de
supprimer la deuxième ligne de l'article
16 bis en effet si nous considérons tout
à fait acceptable de diminuer le nombre
de conseillers municipaux dans les
communes de moins de 100 habitants
par contre dans les communes de 100 à
499 habitants
nous avons à l'heure actuelle une
difficulté puisque les maires qui sont
très très sollicités voit quand même
assez souvent le nombre de leurs
coéquipiers fondre au fil des années au
cours d'un mandat et ils ont de plus en
plus la charge d'avoir à assister à de
multiples réunions dans le cadre de
l'intercommunalité et dans des communes
de cette taille là il ne paraît pas très
bon de diminuer le nombre
voilà simplement qu'elle est l'objet de
cet amendement merci chers collègues
deux amendements identiques le 64
rectifier il est présenté par monsieur
detraigne
oui bien sûr prison il s'agit d'un
amendement complémentaires dans la même
logique celui qui a été intégrée dans le
texte par la commission des lois il
concerne aujourd'hui ce qui est une
strate la strate de 500 à 1000 499
habitants
il vous propose de diviser cette strate
en deux parce qu'il ya une quand même
une grande différence entre une commune
de 500 2 500 habitants est une commune
de 1499 habitants et donc on vous
propose d'une part de couper cette
strate en deux et de réduire dans la
même logique que ce qui a déjà été
inscrits le nombre de sièges
merci chers collègues l'amendement 295
il est présenté comme monsieur kalt
hommes bas coût du lait huile et il est
défendu
il est défendu jeu excusez moi mais je
reviens sur le sous-amendement 358
rectifié de terre qui peut être
présentée je pense par monsieur opère
je suis président je suis ministre je
vous remercie de le prendre en compte
parce que on parle beaucoup de seuil
mais entre cent et 0 habitants il ya un
seuil qui est 50 et qui pourrit quai
pour moi important parce que il ya
beaucoup de communes de moins de 50
habitants dans mon dans mon département
qui ont vraiment des problèmes de quorum
j'ai même des communes de vingt
habitants où il n'y a pas assez de
personnes adultes pour être conseiller
municipal donc on trouve des maisons
secondaires donc il n'y a pas de il ya
des problèmes de quorum et je suis
d'accord avec monsieur lézard au dessus
de 100 jusqu'à 500 habitants ça serait
dangereux de baisser le seuil puisque là
nous aurions des problèmes de
représentation à l'intercommunalité donc
moi mon seuil c'est 50 en dessous tu en
dessous de 57 et le reste on ne change
pas la loi
merci merci chers collègues nous avons
deux amendements identiques que le 259
rectifié 325 4 259 tombe sur le 325
alain lipietz
il est pris il est défendu
il est défendu d'accord nous en arrivons
au 65 et rectifiée présentée par
monsieur détraigne ainsi que le 66
rectifié peut-être oui puisque on boucle
l'ensemble du tableau des dix nombre de
membres des conseils municipaux
pourquoi je les fais en plusieurs
amendement parce que la problématique
n'est pas forcément la même dans toutes
les communes il y as certainement une
constante qui est que dans les petites
communes on a du mal à constituer un
conseil municipal cohérent dans les
grandes communes mais là je me connais
beaucoup moins je pense d'elle et les
villes
oui moi je suis milieu dans l'est dans
l'est et dans les grandes villes
on a beaucoup de monde sans complice
dire que tout le monde soit réellement
impliqué dans la vie du conseil
municipal donc il ya certainement un
juste milieu
au travers de l'ensemble de mes
amendements je pense qu'on approche ce
juste milieu en tout cas moi qui suis
dans une catégorie où je suis censé j'ai
aujourd'hui 27 conseillers municipaux
sur le papier venant de la liste que je
conduisais de la liste qui constitue
l'opposition cote
en moyenne nous sommes 22 présents cc je
me plains pas parce que par rapport à
d'autres collègues je n'ai pas à me
plaindre
nous sommes 22 présents sur 27 sur les
cinq manquant il y en a trois qui
pensent à faire ma pouvoir et puis deux
d'autres constatent qu'ils sont pas là
et il avait l'air tout aussi motivés au
moment des élections que les autres mais
on sait très bien que
que on a toujours une perte de
motivation en cours de mandat et qu'on
invente parfois on le voit en ce moment
avec l'élargissement des
intercommunalités des délégations
pittoresque en tout cas dans
l'appellation et pittoresque le dock
en plus quand on est dans une ville les
décisions sont prises par les élus dieu
merci mais leur mise en oeuvre
c'est les services de la collectivité
donc on peut même pas dire on a besoin
d'eux pour mon pour monter le stand à la
kermesse c'est que du tout ça donc je
crois que pour des raisons différentes
mais d'un bout à l'autre détail de
collectivités on peut aller j'ai pas
forcément du même nom brin d'ailleurs je
parlerai dans le détail mais on peut
alléger les le quota prévu aujourd'hui
pour constituer une liste au conseil
municipal
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur quelle est la vie la
commission nous commençons donc par le
358 rectifia soeur président de la
commission avait l'avis suivant était
d'accord pour baisser le nombre de
membres pour la tranche de moins de 100
habitants
9 à 7 et pour la tranche de 100 à 499 de
11 à 9
c'est la position de la commission jma
n'en met je dois vous dire à l'ecoute du
débat je ne crois pas qu'il faille
j'allais dire se précipiter dans une
diminution globale des nombres et je
suis même hésitant suite à une
conversation sur les conséquences
qu'aurait la diminution de la tranche
100 à 499
on est sur des conseils municipaux
limité or je serai à titre personnel le
seul président pour recommander la
diminution pour la tranche de moins de
100 habitants j'en resterai là pour le
reste
merci monsieur le ministre quel est
l'avis du gouvernement merci monsieur le
président le gouvernement avait été
attentif au travail de la commission à
savoir que l'initiative prix sur la
baisse concernant les deux premières
tranches nous paraissait une initiative
opportune
a contrario continuer à appliquer cette
règle sur l'ensemble des autres tranches
je pense change un peu la nature du
débat et les arguments sont pas de même
de même portée et donc le gouvernement
on souhaiterait qu'on en reste
est ce que la commission avait proposé
et qui ne concernerait que les deux
premières tranches
et de ce point de vue nous mettons donc
un avis défavorable sur l'ensemble des
amendements et sous-amendement et qui
irait dans le sens contraire
merci monsieur le ministre
donc nous sommes sur le 358 rectifié de
terre
c'est une demande d'explication vote
madame ou monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues et moi
je vais suivre l'avis de la commission
c'est de soutenir l'amendement de
monsieur mézard sous-amendé pour une
raison pour une raison assez simple mon
suppléant à une commune de 24 habitants
donc neuf dans un conseil municipal
c'est très compliqué c'est même
quasiment impossible donc je suis
parfaitement ce que dit monsieur opère
d'autant que dans mon département il ya
30 % des communes qui ont moins de 500
habitants et qui ont beaucoup de mal
mais ma
donnez des délégations à certain nombre
de membres de leur conseil municipal
tant de l'intercommunalité a finalement
rendu obsolète là une partie de leurs
fonctions néanmoins pour la solidarité
et pour le lien indispensable entre les
conseillers municipaux et l'action
municipale je pense qu'il faut aussi
conserver un nombre de conseillers
municipaux suffisant et l'argumentaire
de monsieur bizarre me semble
particulièrement pertinent dans les
communes de 500 habitants
oui mais c'est quand même important
parce qu'il ya le lien avec la
population et en milieu rural le fait
que les gens soient membres d'un conseil
municipal permet de diffuser aussi
l'information et de rendre à cette
nombre de services donc encore une fois
moi je soutient l'amendement de monsieur
mézard sous-amendé par monsieur houpert
monsieur mézard pour explication de vote
que le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues je remercie le
rapport de la commission de son avis
personnel je pense effectivement que
c'est la sagesse de diminuer un peu dans
les communes de moins de 100 habitants
parce que c'est pas facile de trouver
neuf personnes mais au delà
faisons attention là nous n'allons pas
faire d'économies dans le fonctionnement
de la démocratie
nous allons écarter un certain nombre de
nos concitoyens de la vie démocratique
municipal alors j'entends bien
l'argument selon lequel parce que je le
soutiens moi même au fil des années il
ya un certain nombre d'élus municipaux
qui s'évapore mais c'est pas parceque
vous diminuerez le nombre des élus qui
sévère qu'en proportion il ne
s'évaporeront pas - ou plus ça sera
exactement la même chose sauf qu'on aura
un réservoir moins important alors
certes il peut y avoir ceux qui sont
derrière qui monte mais je crois que
justement nous avons et nous l'avons
tous dit depuis des années y compris
lorsque nous combattions pour certains
d'entre nous la loi rct nous avons avec
les élus municipaux un moyen de re les
dents sur le territoire de lien social
qui est inégalable et qui celui là ne
coûte rien alors pourquoi pourquoi aller
le démolir je crois que ce ne serait pas
une bonne image sous sous prétexte de
simplification et bien on va rendre un
peu plus difficile
le fonctionnement de nos conseils
municipaux donc je crois vraiment pas
qu'il faille aller sur ce terrain là
merci chocolat et monsieur mort est le
merci aux seules présentes se présente
seule miss mes chers collègues
la question du
de la diminution des effectifs des
conseils municipaux des petites communes
c'est une vraie question
parce que c'est une question qui que se
posent les élus et j'avoue que je
n'avais moi même pas d'idée arrêtée
parce que je rencontrais des élus qui
trouvait qu'il fallait réduire le nombre
demandent leur conseil municipal ou
al'inverse qu'il fallait surtout le
préserver et quand j'ai vu le dispositif
adopté par la commission des lois comme
je suis un adepte de la démocratie
participative
j'ai adressé un mail à tous les maires
concernés de mon département et j'ai été
très étonné de voir que finalement il y
avait une grande majorité d'entre eux je
dis pas la totalité mais une très grande
majorité d'entre eux qui ne souhaitait
pas la diminution des effectifs du
conseil municipal pourquoi si je prends
les principaux arguments qui ont été mis
en avant
premier argument c'est pour permettre
une meilleure représentation de
l'ensemble de la population par amo par
tranche d'âge bar origine
professionnelle deuxième argument c'est
la question de deux des équipes et de du
fait d'avoir suffisamment de personnes
pour mettre la main à la pâte parce que
je vous rappelle que dans une petite
commune est bien très souvent les élus
mettent la main à la pâte
c'est eux qui vont aller repeindre la
salle des fêtes c'est eux qui vont tenir
les bureaux de vote et on nous dit
qu'ils seront bientôt peut-être tenu
jusqu'à 20 heures
c'est eux qui vont faire quantité de
deux tâches comme celle que j'évoque et
puis autre argument qui est peut-être
encore plus fort c'est celui de dire
mais pourquoi on nous en veut on ne
coûte rien les conseillers municipaux
s'étaient rappelés sont des bénévoles
pourquoi vouloir réduire le nombre de
conseils municipaux et beaucoup y voient
les prémices d'une volonté que prête
souvent les élus locaux au pouvoir
central de vouloir supprimer les
communes et donc je trouve que c'est un
très mauvais signal qu'on envoie avec
cet article
aux communes rurales et je trouve que si
on devait s'engager vers une diminution
des effectifs des conseils municipaux
alors il faudrait généraliser à toutes
les strates moi je suis maire d'une
commune de plus de 10000 habitants
personnellement ça ne me poserait aucun
problème qu'on retire quelques quelques
conseils municipaux donc s'attaquer
uniquement ou en tout cas
visé par cet article uniquement les
communes les plus petites je trouve que
c'est un mauvais signal et donc pour
cette raison je suis défavorable à à
l'article et et à l'ensemble des
amendements
merci monsieur laménie à paroles oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues nous on c'est
sûr que au niveau de cet amendement et
je rejoins aussi et je comprends notre
collègue ou pas on perd bon après pour
jusque 100 habitants est ce qu'on doit
réduire en deux tranches saint moins de
50 habitants et jusque 100 habitants
c'est pas simple je reconnais que c'est
vraiment vraiment pas simple de l'autre
côté j'ai entendu l'intervention de
monsieur le reporter et c'est vrai que
le le mérite dans ce texte revient à
l'ensemble des collègues de la
commission des lois et j'irai ils ont
aussi passé beaucoup d'énergie a
vraiment essayé de d'améliorer
d'améliorer ce ce texte est je crois
qu'il faut pas réduire beaucoup et je
crois que la solution proposée par le
rapporteur et soucis ou la sagesse je
vais dans ce sens aussi
bon c'est sûr que pour les communes de
moins de 100 habitants on a parfois
souvent même du mal à trouver les
quelques bonnes volontés et c'est pas
simple c'est pas le tout d'être de dire
jouët au conseil municipal
après il faut aussi s'investirait est
travaillé bénévolement un croco tous les
collègues l'ont dit et je le redis
vraiment aussi avec beaucoup de force et
beaucoup de conviction ce que tout
repose mais c'est aussi là la richesse
de cette implication dans nos petites
communes et l'implication des bonnes
volontés mais c'est pas simple et c'est
vrai que après deux dans la tranche 100
à 500 habitants je crois réduire encore
plus c'est pas évident parce que j'irai
bon souvent les gars le maire bd fois un
adjoint voire deux adjoints mais guère
plus et puis après il faut aussi
vraiment que les collègues du conseil
six plaques paul s'impliquent
bénévolement
parce qu'après il ya toutes sortes de
délégations qui s'ajoute
dans les charges de représentativité ici
et là ce qui se passe dans la commune on
trouve encore quelques bonnes volontés
quand c'est dans la commune siège mais
après quand il s'agit de de se déplacer
à différentes réunions extérieur ben là
il ya moins de volontaires pour le faire
et c'est là qu'on voit que l'échelon de
base que ken aux communes c'est vraiment
l'échelon de proximité d'efficacité et
contient vraiment toutes et tous à
défendre je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le président parce que le débat
a permis l'échangé d'arguments
intéressant et dans un souci de prendre
en compte les arguments qui ont été
changés le gouvernement sur l'amendement
de monsieur méar s'en remet à la sagesse
votre assemblée
bon je reste simplement vous dire que
monsieur vous aviez retirer en fait
votre amendement 350 2 oui donc le 358
rectifié tomber
donc nous sommes en fait sur le 64
rectifier voilà donc je ne sais pas
alors il y avait quelques personnes qui
voulaient intervenir ils vont peut-être
vouloir intervenir donc c'est mais je
recadre bien sûr le 64 rectifier j'avais
une demande de parole de monsieur y est
oui monsieur le président je pense que
les explications de vote voteront pour
tous les amendements à wasquehal et tout
ce qui a été dit parce que si on
recommence à chaque fois on sera encore
là demain soir franchement il ya quand
même on a on a quand même intérêt à
synthétiser un petit peu les propos sur
le président je fais deux observations
moi j'étais d'accord avec le point de
vue de la commission je crois que des
très petites communes il ya quand même
un problème de trouver des conseillers
bon moi je connais des cas il ya des
communes de 35 habitants de 60 habitants
on n'arrive même pas franchement c'est
très difficile de trouver 9
et puis certains en plus voulais pas que
ce soit ceux de la même famille alors là
c'était la fin des haricots
on pourrait pu composer le conseil
municipal mais j'observe
et ça va nous poser un problème veuillez
m'excuser on a fixé le seuil à 1000 pour
les scrutins liste or le seuil de 15
cents existe pour le nombre de conseils
municipaux dont il y avait selon à 1000
il y aura ce que thalys mais il sait le
même nombre qu'à qu'un sens où est la
difficulté c'est pour ça aussi et je les
ai pas dit ce matin j'ai eu tort
pourquoi on avait aussi proposé qu'un
sens parce que c'était un seuil en
fonction du nombre de conseillers
municipaux savez quand même sa logique
parce que ça veut dire que pour les
mêmes la même tranche
il y aura liste ou pas liste et c'est
quand même un petit peu curieux vous
avouerez de créer 7 ce qui existait déjà
pour 2500 3500 et on l'a supprimée mais
on a créé une nouvelle disparités je
voulais le noter quand même
la parole est à monsieur opère oui
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
chers collègues je reviens sur drôme ou
sous-amendement parce que je pense qu'il
est important de chaque côté de la
mystique on a parlé de quorum difficulté
d'avoir un quorum et de baisse de
motivation en cours de mandat et je
pense que la masse critique c'est ses
cinquante habitants parce qu'en dessous
c'est la quadrature du cercle
on ne trouvera pas neuf conseillers
c'est pas possible et élargir la baisse
à la 9 jusqu'à 500 je pense que c'est
excessif parce que nous aurons des
problèmes de représentation dans dans
les intercommunalités voilà merci merci
j'avais une demande de pardon kaltenbach
le groupe socialiste va se rallier à la
proposition du rapporteur en votant donc
l'amendement de monsieur mézard de façon
à ce que la seule baisse soit pour les
communes de moins de 100 habitants où on
passerait de neuf conseillers à sept
conseillers je crois que tout ce qui a
été dit dans l'hémicycle le montre bien
que c'est une diminution indispensable
et ensuite pour le reste du tableau je
crois qu'il faut attendre de voir vous
s'établira le seuil et quels débats
auront lieu à l'assemblée puis ensuite
en seconde lecture on pourra revenir
peut-être éventuellement la marge le
groupe socialiste avait déposé un
amendement de coordination pour que en
effet comme l'a souligné le sénateur y
est il y ait au passage du seuil à 1020
nombre de conseillers différents pour
qu'on allait proposer sur 295 d'avoir
une tranche intermédiaire entre 500 et
1000 à 13 puis de 1000 à 1500 à 15 donc
nous retirons cet amendement et nous
verrons sont ni tueur
s'il a lieu de revenir sur ce débat et
le groupe socialiste votera contre tous
les amendements
sauf celui de monsieur lézard merci
messieurs sido à la parole
oui monsieur le président je vais dire
deux choses la première c'est celle que
vous avez dit que je voudrais rajouter
c'est à dire que le gouvernement
ailleurs ayant retiré son amendement
1 actuellement le soudan nord 2 me saoul
père tombe
quelles que soient les qualités
d'ailleurs de la bande de super et la
qualité de ce sénateur hop r b derrière
je peux lui dire qu' il peut sous-amendé
en séance un autre amendement d'ailleurs
c'est une proposition que je lui fais le
deuxième point j'allais dire exactement
les mêmes choses qu'eux mais ce qu'elle
tombe là que je soutient effectivement
la commission c'est plus simple et au
fond l'argument de monsieur lézard de
dire qu'il y avait une évaporation
apporte de l'eau au moulin de dire qu'il
en faut plus pour que finalement à la
fin on me met suffisamment voilà ce que
je voulais dire merci merci monsieur
masson parole pour l'association de vote
moi je
je pense que c'était pas obligatoirement
nécessaire de mettre en cause dans ce
projet de loi les répartitions de de
nombre de sièges dans les petites
communes
et ce qui pose un petit peu problème
c'est que on sent enfin on cible les
petites communes sans sans rien voir
dans d'autres communes et moi je pense
que non seulement on pourrait réfléchir
dans une bonne logique de bonne
administration et surtout d'économie des
fonds publics à réduire les effectifs
dans les grandes communes mais aussi
dans les conseils généraux dans les
conseils régionaux et il ya peut-être
plus d'argent à ce niveau-là à
économiser on est dans la logique de
bonne gestion des fonds publics que 220
d'évoquer le problème des petites
communes
alors ceci étant moi je pense je crois
que bon à la limite pour les communes de
moins de 100 habitants les faire passer
à 7
c'est pas aberrant parce que bon bouge
dans le département de la moselle il ya
des communes qui ont vingt habitants bon
camp et 20 habitants j'ai une commune de
l'heure quand j'étais député et la v20
habitants est toujours 20e électeurs et
vat habitants 21 électeurs ils sont ce
qu il va y avoir un propriétaire foncier
qui était qui et électeurs dans la
commune c'est quand même pas facile pour
trouver neuf personnes à ce niveau là
est actuellement même en moselle il ya
des communes quand vous venez dans ces
petites communes il ya vous allez chez
le maire il ya la femme du maire la
fille du maire etc où il ya la moitié du
conseil municipal parce que compte tenu
que les communes n'y a presque pas
d'habitants ils sont bien obligés
d'avoir des gens dans la même famille
procès c'est une ou deux familles qui
représente qui constitue à elle seule le
conseil municipal
merci alors si vous le voulez bien nous
prenons tous dans l'ordre ah pardon
monsieur détraigne excuses mans
je ne sais pas si j'ai encore le droit
de parler parce que j'ai présenté mes
amendements mais je voulais dire un
argument qu on a peu entendu à propos du
64 rectifié parce que je crois que c'est
sur celui là que l'on est
ouais mais mais je peux parler du 515
rectifié maintenant tout je disais tout
à l'heure qu'il coupait en deux strates
une strate actuelle qui va de 500 à 1000
499 habitants nous avons en fin de
matinée instauré à partir de 1000
habitants
un mode de scrutin différent de celui
qu'il ya entre 500 et 999 habitants
je crois que cela renforce la nécessité
de voir la répartition passe pourquoi ça
a été dit ce matin dans les opposants à
l'extension du scrutin de liste c'est
quoi la difficulté de constituer les
listes et de dire si on abaisse trop le
seuil du scrutin de liste il n'y aura
plus qu'une nice elle sera déjà
suffisamment difficile à faire il y aura
un désintérêt de la population pour les
élections municipales alors que c'est
l'élection qui tient le plus à coeur aux
habitants de nos communes je pense qu'il
faut prendre ça en compte
et alors bon sur les petites strates
d'accord faut peut-être simplement
enlevé en dessous de 2 200 mais moi je
vous mets en garde
si on ne modifie pas un petit peu à la
baisse au dessus de 1000 l'argument que
je viens de vous dire est que j'ai
beaucoup entendu dans mon département et
je suis sûr qu'un certain nombre d'entre
vous en province en tout cas l'ont
entendu cet argument va remonter et va
alors qu'on a voté sans trop de
difficultés ce matin l'abaissement du
seuil de ce que tu as dis donc je crois
qu'à partir de 1000 très bien de
regarder ce que je vous propose de près
merci chers collègues alors nous allons
voter sur l'oncle 258 rectifié appelé
amendement mézard que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veut bien levé la
main
merci que ceux qui sont contre eux bien
je crois qui est adopté à l'unanimité
je rappelle que l'amendement du
gouvernement était retiré le 358 tomber
nous en arrivons donc aux 64 rectifié
pas de plus de demandes d'explications
de vote que ceux qui souhaitent adopter
veut bien levé la main merce si vous
s'il vous plaît que ceux qui sont
pauvres veulent bien levé la main le 64
rectifier merci que ceux qui sont contre
veut bien levé la main il est adopté le
3 125 pas de demandes d'explications de
vote
il est tombé
oui ils tomberont d'accord
absolument et nous en arrivons au 65
rectifier à deux demandes d'explications
de vote que ceux qui souhaitent
l'adopter veut bien levé la main merci
que pendant que ceux qui sont pauvres
veulent bien levé la main merci que ceux
qui sont contre veut bien levé la main
il n'est pas adoptée sur le 66 rectifié
même vote même vote
nous votons sur l'article 16 bis pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé
la main il est adopté
article additionnel après l'article 16
bis zh
l'amendement 180 rectifié qui est
présentée par monsieur masson
et le le projet de loi que nous
examinons cible surtout les communes qui
sont au-delà du seuil où sera appliqué
là la proportionnelle le système
proportionnel avec prime majoritaire
mais dans les petites communes il est
absolument impératif et tout le monde
l'a dit ce matin il absolument impératif
de mettre un peu d'ordre dans le mode de
scrutin qui est héritée de la période du
fanion du du début du 19e siècle avec
toutes les tous les aléas qui peuvent se
poser à ce niveau là et en particulier
je pense que dans un souci de
clarification quelqu'un qui n'est pas
candidat au premier tour ne doit pas
pouvoir être candidat au deuxième jeu
c'est complètement aberrant de de
vouloir disons de dire bah tiens moi je
m'intéresse pas aux élections etc
puis tout d'un coup au deuxième tour de
se réveiller et dire moi je vais être
candidat dans aucune élection prenait
que ce soit les élections présidentielle
et législatives les cantonales et les
régionales dans aucune élection sauf les
municipales des petites communes il est
possible de ne pas être candidat au
premier tour et puis de venir brouiller
les cartes au deuxième tour alors je
pense que c'est pas bon du tout et c'est
le sens de l'amendement que je présente
à ce niveau là merci cher collègue
monsieur rapporteur qu'elle est
défavorable monsieur ministre
défavorable pour explication de vote
monsieur 6 2
merci monsieur le président il m'étonne
de la part de maçon de faire une une
erreur législative parce que dans les
élections sénatoriales où il ya une
élection uninominale à deux tours on
peut être candidat uniquement au
deuxième tour par conséquent son
explication ne tient pas la route
et pour revenir à l'objet de son
amendement pour des raisons de
parallélisme des formes
j'estime qu'on peut très bien dans les
petites communes être candidat au
deuxième tour sans l'être au premier
tour dans la mesure où on a pu constater
qu'au premier tour ça n'allait pas et
bien une personne sort pour le deuxième
tour donc je suis contre cet amendement
merci chers collègues je n'ai pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement avait bien levé la main merci
que ceux qui sont contre veuille bien
levé la main l'amendement n'est pas
adopté un article additionnel après
l'article 16 devises seul amendement 382
est présentée par monsieur le rapporteur
au nom de la commission des lois
ce président c'est un amendement de
conséquence il vient suite au
l'évolution du nombre de délégués des
conseils municipaux dans le collège
électoral des sénateurs simplement pour
indiquer que le nombre de délégués
sénatoriaux par commune reste inchangé
par rapport au droit en vigueur
malgré les modifications que nous venons
de décider
merci monsieur le ministre la ville
gouvernement favorable avis favorable je
n'ai pas de demandes d'explications de
vote que ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter
veuille bien levé la main unanimité je
vous remercie
un moment sur l'article 17 1 mais j'ai
d'abord une demande de parole de
monsieur jean louis masson
oui disons que cet article je la trouve
tout à fait car il entre dans la logique
que j'ai expliqué à l'instant qui
consiste à mes tops d'ordre dans l'est
et dans les systèmes de présentation de
candidature et dans l'organisation des
élections municipales dans les petites
communes je pense que c'était absolument
indispensable sous la réserve que les
solutions retenues aussi bien d'un
projet gouvernemental que dans ce cas
choix qu'a décidé la commission des lois
ne vont pas assez loin je pense qu'on
devrait enfin c'était l'objet du présent
amendement et j'en ai plusieurs que je
voudrais présenter et c'est la logique
du système je pense que le mode de
scrutin dans les petites communes doit
être recadrées recadrer et nettement
mieux recadrer que s'il l'est dans le
projet que nous examinons merci alors
l'amendement 360 capter présentée par
monsieur le rapporteur au nom de la
commission des lois
monsieur le président il s'agit d'un
amendement de conséquence de la
modification qui est proposé à l'article
17 la commission art group à l'article
10 7 le régime de l'obligation
candidature dans les communes de moins
de 1000 habitants en conséquence elle
défavorable à l'ensemble des autres
amendements à cet article 17 ha
merci monsieur le ministre quel est
l'avis du gouvernement merci monsieur le
président le gouvernement n'est pas
favorable à l'amendement qui est
présenté par le rapporteur c'est à dire
le 364 puisque le gouvernement souhaite
émettre un avis favorable sur un
amendement qui a été déposée par
monsieur mézard sur le même sujet qui
serait l'amendement numéro 261 qui est
plus complet qui vise un objectif qui
sur lequel le gouvernement souhaite
donner un avis favorable donc en l'état
le gouvernement suggère le retrait de
l'amendement numéro 3 164 au profit d'un
avis favorable qu'il donnera sur
l'amendement numéro 261
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieur rapporte ans avait cru
comprendre que l'amendement que j'ai
présenté au nom de la commission des
lois par est plus complet que
l'amendement monsieur mézard et c'est
cela m'arrive exceptionnellement c'est
pour ça que j'hésite à le dire aussi
clairement il était déjà bien complet le
mien est complet plus donc je n'arrive
pas à comprendre que le gouvernement
fasse un choix différent mais c'est sa
liberté
donc je ne suis pas favorable avec celui
de monsieur mézard parce que je préfère
le mien aussi simple que ça j'ai bien
compris on dire que vous que vous le
maniez vous le maintenez monsieur le
ministre sur le complet plus complet en
l'état en l'état de l'ess en l'état de
la situation et les deux amendements
coexistant le gouvernement maintient sa
position sous réserve de l'évolution du
débat très bien alors nous allons
d'abord donc nous prononcer sur le 364
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter
l'amendement 364 veuille bien levé la
main c'est l'amendement de la commission
8 9 10 11
merci que ceux qui 12 que ceux qui sont
contre et bien levé la main et bien
l'amendement est adopté et l'article
donc est supprimé il clôt 17 j'ai donc
une demande de parole de monsieur masson
tic ne correspond pas comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure cet article correspond à
mon souhait de devoir recadrer un petit
peu le système électoral et donc je me
réjouis de cet article que je voterai
que je tiens à voter mais je crois qu'il
serait peut-être pertinent d'aller un
peu plus loin comme je l'aï déjà dit
tout à l'heure il ya un ensemble de
d'anomalies qui continuent à subsister
et je crois qu'il faut aussi mieux
recadrer les dépôts de candidatures les
déclarations de candidature car ça
permettrait en recadrant les conditions
de dépôt de candidatures en donnant plus
notamment que les candidats sauf gétigné
leur candidature et cetera ça
permettrait de mieux que l'arrêté les
choses merci chers collègues
l'amendement 121 tombe et nous avons
donc huit amendements qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune est tout
d'abord trois amendements identiques le
221 est présentée par monsieur pokémon
vaincus comme le 3 le 221 madame kerman
le 221
il est défendu
il est défendu il est défendu merci le
331 rectifier et présentée par monsieur
détraigne ou par monsieur m'aurait par
monsieur détraigne
un peu là ici
oui c'est un amendement qui propose de
supprimer les alinéa 4 et 5
j'allais dire par mesure de
simplification que les règles soient les
mêmes dans toutes les communes de moins
de 1000 habitants qui sont d'ailleurs
les communes qui ont le même mode de
scrutin
voilà le moment 356 présenté par le
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
oui merci monsieur le président le
gouvernement a été attentif à
l'intention de la commission des lois de
prévoir le dépôt de candidatures dans
toutes les communes il nous semblait
effectivement nécessaire de mettre fin à
cette tradition conduisant à ce qu'une
personne non candidate puisse tout de
même être élu mais il paraît nécessaire
d'harmoniser les exigences applicables à
ces communes si les quatrième et
cinquième alinéas de l'article 17 ter
qui sont rédigées renvoie aux formes
prévues par les cinq premiers alinéas de
l'article l de 165 du code électoral or
cet article renvoie lui-même à d'autres
articles du code électoral qui impose
notamment le dépôt de liste complète est
paritaire il ne semble pas que les telle
était la volonté de la commission des
lois
en effet imposer de telles conditions
alors que dans ces communes des
candidatures ont parfois de la peine à
émerger constitueraient un risque pour
le pluralisme et pourraient donc
conduire à l'absence de candidature le
gouvernement propose donc de supprimer
ces deux alinéas
merci monsieur ministre l'amendement 365
est présentée par monsieur le rapporteur
la commission des lois
c'est à mon nom fait l'objet d'un
retrait de ma part moi je suis d'accord
avec la proposition présentée par le
gouvernement qui évoque d'ailleurs celle
qu'avait présenté madame à 106 va dans
le même sens le 200 rectifié tombant le
129 rectifié terre est présentée par
monsieur détraigne oui c'est un
amendement qui prévoit la déclaration de
candidature pour chaque tour de scrutin
pour les communes de 500 à 999 habitants
comme ces cas pour les communes de moins
de 500 habitants
ou comme ce sera le cas pour la commune
de massat service vise habitants et pour
celles de plus de 1000 habitants
il paraît pas logique de faire une
différence de traitement pour cette
seule strates l'amendement 380 et
présentée par monsieur rapporteur au nom
de la commission
il est retiré ou
il n'est pas retirée
d'accord donc il est défendu et j'ai un
sous-amendement de monsieur masson qui
est de 374 rectifier j'avais moi même
déposé un amendement sur le problème de
l'affichage mais qui est tombé dans dans
l'article précédent et j'avais déposé un
amendement 374 et je les transformer en
sous-amendement pour le faire subsister
je pense il convient toujours dans la
logique d'éviter les fins de clarifier
un petit peu les élections municipales
dans les petites communes
je pense qu'il est très important de
prévoir que les gens ne puissent pas
être candidat dans plusieurs communes ni
dans plusieurs sections électorales
baissier des communes il ya certains
départements où il ya beaucoup de
sections électorales
et sinon une même personne pour être
candidate dans deux sections électorales
de la même commune ce qui n'est pas
interdit actuellement et je pense que là
aussi il faut que les gens sachent ce
qu'ils veulent et que ma foi on puisse
pas être candidat au moment des
élections municipales dans plusieurs
endroits différents
merci chers collègues alors monsieur le
rapporteur général la vis sur l'ensemble
des amendements d'accord et donc sur les
autres soit son expansion monsieur
ministre l'avis du gouvernement donc
l'avis du gouvernement est également
favorable sur le sous-amendement de de
monsieur masson et pour l'adoption donc
de l'amendement que nous avions déposé
ainsi qu'un amendement favorable sur
l'amendement qui avait été déposé par
380 voilà ce qu'il nous votons les trois
premiers les autres tombes
sauf à partir du 380 sous-amendé par
monsieur masson c'est ce qui explique
effectivement les prises de position de
la commission du gouvernement
donc je vous propose si vous le voulez
bien de voter dans un premier temps sur
l'amendement 221
1 331 rectifié de 356 identiques qui
propose de la suppression d aline r 4 et
y at il des demandes d'explications de
vote
s'il n'y en a pas que ceux qui sont pour
adopter ces amendements veuille bien
levé la main merci ils sont adoptés
donc le 365 été rectifié le deux sens
était tombé 129 rectifié tomber et nous
en arrivons donc aux 380 pour lequel
nous avons un avis favorable du
gouvernement est d'abord le 374
sous-amendement pour lequel nous avons
deux avis favorable sur le 374
explications de vote de monsieur longuet
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
mon cher collègue votre sous-amendement
374 me rend perplexe perplexe parce que
on ne peut être électeur que dans une
seule commune
on peut être élu dans différentes
communes le mandat local est un mandat
de gestion qu'une personnalité qui est
éligible dans plusieurs communes veuille
répartir ces risques en confiant aux
électeurs des différentes communes le
choix de lui indiquer la commune dans
lequel on va le retenir ne me paraît pas
choquant nous ne sommes pas dans la
logique de la troisième république ou a
jusqu à un certain moment qui est auquel
il a été mis fin par les excès du
général boulanger qui avait transformé
les élections législatives en plébiscite
nationaux par le jeu de la multi
candidature je crois que le boulanger
avait été candidat dans plus de soixante
soixante dix circonscriptions à faisant
ainsi un appel direct au peuple nous
sommes pas dans ce cas de figure sommes
dans le cas de figure de quelqu'un qui a
des intérêts légitimes dans des communes
dans lequel il n'est pas électeur mais
il est éligible qu'il laisse aux
électeurs le soin de savoir s'il est un
administrateur
après tout c'est une responsabilité qui
appartient aux électeurs
je ne voit pas malice à être candidat
dans plusieurs communes aux sections de
communes puisque on remet aux électeurs
le soin de vous désigne est évident que
s'il était élu dans plusieurs communes
saint pée crée un problème de choix et
c'est sans doute un cas de figure qui
doit être réglé puisque aujourd'hui
c'est possible si c'était pas possible
vous ne riez pas présenter votre
sous-amendement il est donc possible
d'être élu dans plusieurs communes vous
fait évidemment confiance à la ridt
libre responsabilité de du conseil élu
sur la commune qu'il choisit et donc
pense très honnêtement que ce côté
anecdotique qui n'a pas de dimension
politique pourrait être toléré c'est la
raison pour laquelle une fois n'est pas
coutume je ne vous soutiendrai pas dans
ce texte sur votre amant votre
sous-amendement merci chers collègues je
n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote nous votons sur
le 374 rectifier que ceux qui souhaitent
adopter veut bien levé la main merci que
ceux qui sont contre veuille bien levé
la main eh bien il est adopté nous
votons maintenant sur le 380 pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter veut bien levé la
main que ceux qui sont contre veut bien
levé la main l'amendement est adopté
nous votons maintenant sur l'article 17
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
si madame longue et madame boulet et ses
présidents ministres mes chers collègues
je n'aurais pas je repars allonger
inutilement ces débats mais l'amendement
de suppression de l'article 17 à a fait
en sorte que les amendements et
notamment le 91 rectifié de monsieur
jarlier cosigné par moi-même tombe
s'agissant des modalités obligatoire des
candidatures pour pour les petites
communes et et j'espère que la deuxième
lecture nous permettra de vérifier
puisque il ya la déclaration obligatoire
mais il ya aussi les modalités de cette
déclaration notamment le dépôt effectué
en sous-préfecture et la nécessité des
délais pour respecter les campagnes dans
les petites communes parce que
finalement
on a cette obligation mais on a toujours
des risques est précisément la série
d'amendements déposés par monsieur
jarlier donc le 91 rectifier le 172e
rectifier le 128 permettez c'est de la
barre en 172 rectifier et 91 rectifié
permettait d'apporter des précisions
quant aux modalités de candidature pour
éviter les candidatures éventuellement
fantaisistes comme nous pouvons en avoir
parfois dans des communes et des
candidatures sauvage entre guillemets
donc le j'espère que la seconde lecture
permettra de déplacer ces amendements
qui était prévu sur l'article 17 à
supprimer à l'article 17 quand il nous
reviendra de l'assemblée je remercie le
gouvernement de nous avoir donné une
lecture complète et non pas une
procédure d'urgence sur ce texte qui est
extrêmement important merci madame
boulet je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent
monsieur le rapporteur précisions par
rapport à ce que je viens d'entendre
parce que dans la monde monde monsieur
mézard figurent toutes les dispositions
que souhaite madame sur les modalités de
déclaration candidature précisions sur
important monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole pour dire pour dire à monsieur
le rapporteur que effectivement c'était
la raison pour laquelle tout à l'heure
j'avais marqué dans un premier temps la
préférence pour la rédaction était
proposée par par monsieur par monsieur
lézard qui donnait les précisions qui
paraissent nécessaires pour compléter
l'intelligibilité de la loi dans tous
les cas sa précision donc je pense que
nous pourrons en cours de la navette
rapprocher nos points de vue parce que
l'objectif semble le même sauf qu'il ya
pu y avoir une incompréhension sur la
manière d'y parvenir
merci monsieur ministre alors nous
votons sur l'article 17 que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veut bien levé la
main merci oppose izik que ceux qui sont
contre
il est adopté un article additionnel
après l'article 17 3 amendements font
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement 180
1 et présentée par monsieur masson oui
monsieur le président j'aurais évoqué un
problème qui se pose dans les petites
communes et où le l'absence
d'information de beaucoup d'électeurs et
de beaucoup d'élus conduit souvent à des
situations aberrantes
en effet actuellement quand on a un
primat bulletins de vote avec plus de
n'ont plus de nom que deux sièges à
pourvoir
ou lorsque les lecteurs rajoute des noms
et bien le bulletin n'est pas nul ce
sont les derniers noms figurant sur le
bulletin qui sont annulés alors ça pose
de problème parce que d'abord con quand
les noms sont sur deux colonnes
est ce que ce sont les trois derniers de
la colonne de droite ou en béton les
quatre derniers lacaune de droite ou les
deux derniers de chacune des deux
colonnes de ressasser un débat
inextricable et en plus la quasi
totalité de nos électeurs ne savent pas
ça 1 et donc dans beaucoup de communes
par exemple il ya des gens qui font des
faux des bulletins de vote et qui pour
s'associer le maximum de personnes qui
aient fait notre batteur on te mettra
sur la liste etc
mais s'ils prennent soin bien évidemment
un de rien dire à personne de se mettre
devant en sachant très bien que comme
les électeurs sont pas très bien informé
neuf fois sur dix la moitié des
bulletins qui sont mis sur des bulletins
en bloc sans sans ajustement du nombre
de non sens s'enrayer suffisamment non
pour correspondre au système et je pense
que c'est
c'est presque une entourloupe dans
certains cas lorsqu'il ya peu de gens et
en plus alors en toute bonne foi il ya
des maires et des adjoints qui ne le
savent même pas me jeter dans une petite
commune de mon département
enfin une commune de 800 habitants de
mon département il ya ya ya trois jours
le maire est tombé du ciel quand j'en ai
parlé à lui il le savait pas et son
adjoint ne le savait pas non plus donc
je crois que là il faut qu'on veille à
la transparence du scrutin qui ait pas
d'ambiguïté et caetera et cet amendement
contribuer à cette logique de
transparence
merci chers collègues l'amendement 353
est présentée par monsieur le ministre
pour le gouvernement
oui merci monsieur le président c'est un
amendement qui vise à ne pas prendre en
compte dans les bulletins de vote aux
élections municipales les noms des
personnes qui n'auraient pas souscrire à
l'obligation de dépôt de candidatures
dans sa rédaction des articles 17 à es17
dieu présent projet de loi tel qu'il
résulte des travaux de la commission
une déclaration de candidature en
préfecture ou sous-préfecture est
obligatoire dans toutes les communes
pour l'ensemble des candidats
il semble donc logique que les électeurs
puissent se connaître à l'avancé le nom
des candidats de façon à pouvoir faire
leur choix de manière éclairée
mais alors que les personnes non
candidate n'auront pas vocation à être
élu le présent amendement est donc un
amendement de cohérence avec la logique
et qui préside à nos travaux merci
monsieur le ministre et ont soudainement
devant l'amendement 379 présentée par
monsieur mettre son oui monsieur le
président ce sous-amendement en fait
correspond un amendement que j'ai
déposée et que j'avais déposé mais qui
est tombé et donc j'ai j'ai utilisé le
la logique du sous-amendement pour
revenir j'irai à la charge sur mon sujet
alors c'est très bien que le but que la
voix exprimées pour quelqu'un qui n'est
pas candidat ne compte pas mais je pense
que ça il convient de beaucoup mieux
clarifier et de considérer le bulletin
comme nulles si sur un bulletin de
conseil régional ou un bulletin de même
de conseiller général ou député va vous
rayer le nom du suppléant ou vous
remplacez suppléant par quelqu'un
d'autre balle bulletins nuls
bon et je pense que ça serait encore
plus fort un d'ajouter non seulement ce
qui nous est proposé mais de prévoir que
le butin est nulle et à ce moment là les
gens feraient certainement beaucoup plus
attention à ce qu'ils font
monsieur rapporteur quel est l'avis de
la commission s'il vous plaît les trois
hommes sur l'amendement 181
le 379 est favorable 353 du gouvernement
d'accord monsieur le ministre quel est
l'avis du gouvernement évidemment le
gouvernement est favorable à son
amendement est défavorable aux deux sous
un moment si donc nous allons voter sur
l'amendement 181 je n'ai pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé la
main pardon monsieur sido pour
explication de vote
oui explications de vote sur
l'amendement 181 parce qu'il se trouve
que dans les communes où il n'y a pas de
liste et pour éviter de politiser les
élections sous le vent souvent même dans
les petites communes et tout le monde le
comprend sauf en moselle apparemment
tout le monde le comprend on peut être
plus de candidats que de sièges à
pourvoir
et c'est ce qu'on appelle les listes
ouvertes effectivement et nos électeurs
comprennent très bien même dans les
communes de 100 ou 200 habitants il se
trouve que pour être parfaitement
démocratique en plus ces listes sont
faites par liste par ordre alphabétique
et que je me trouvais sur cette liste et
que je m'appelle sido j'étais en queue
de liste alors que j'étais candidat
vraiment candidat donc à vrai dire nos
électeurs comprennent parfaitement faut
pas les prendre pour des imbéciles
pardonnez moi cette expression ils
comprennent parfaitement tout ce
mécanisme électoraux et ils savent
parfaitement ce qu'ils veulent
par conséquent je suis particulièrement
contre cet amendement
180 merci chers collègues
monsieur laménie pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le président
monsieur minister collègues dans la
continuité
je dirais de notre collègue bruno sido
et justement dans le cadre de cet
amendement je dirais je voulais aussi
faire par un peu de d'un témoignage est
justement ce principe de listes ouvertes
bon c'est vrai que je dirais peu dans ma
modeste commune c'est un peu le système
ça sent bon et sont mauvais bon on
n'écarte personne
bon on mais j'irai les conseillers
municipaux sortants break le maire
sortant les conseillers municipaux
sortants
puis après on louvre aux personnes dites
de bonne volonté en le donc après c'est
sûr qu'on peut se retrouver avec pour
onze postes à pourvoir avec une liste
par exemple de 15 noms mais et c'est pas
du tout j'ai dirait pénalisant parce
qu'à un moment donné il suffit dans
l'information bon on est pour
l'information la transparence je crois
que mêmes pour nos petites communes
auxerre est important aussi de
communiquer il faut réellement
communiqué j'irai ont suffi que cantons
ont fait 1 on distribue les papiers tout
bottes
j'irai bas on met un petit bulletin
complémentaire ne laisser que onze noms
au maximum bon à la limite après et on
s'aperçoit que ba j'irai sur les listes
quand on fait le dépouillement il ya
souvent pas mal de noms qui sont rayés
et des fois il reste que cinq noms sinon
c'est non et là on est à chaque fois en
dessous en dessous même d'aider 11 donc
j'irai je rejoins mon collègue bruno
sido
et c'est vrai peut comprendre aussi le
cet amendement mais donc je serai aussi
défavorable par rapport à cet amendement
jour merci merci chers collègues pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement va bien levé la main merci
que ceux qui sont contre veuille bien
levé la main l'amendement n'est pas
adopté l'amendement le sous-amendement
379 que ceux qui souhaitent adopter va
bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre va bien
levé la main il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 353 même vote non pas
pardon pas même vote non non non non
nous allons voter que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veuille bien levé
la main merci que ceux qui sont contre
vais bien levé la main l'amendement est
adopté
article additionnel après l'article 17
de 187 tombe
nous en arrivons à l'amendement 182 qui
est présentée par monsieur masson
c'est la reprise de ce que j'ai dit
monsieur le président donc je vais me
retirer parce que je pense que disons
comme le sous-amendement été retiré et
il en est de même à ce niveau là
collet amendement numéro 2 123 il est
présenté par monsieur wauquiez
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous avons
indiqué ce matin à l'occasion de nos
échanges que nous sommes bien sûr
favorable fondamentalement au scrutin de
liste qui garantit la parité et
l'application de la proportionnelle pour
toutes les communes
cela supposerait de mettre en place un
dispositif particulier pour les plus
petites d'entre elles afin bien sûr de
prendre en compte leurs spécificités
plus le temps de réflexion nous aurait
sans doute permis de construire des
modalités du scrutin qui aurait permis
cette mesure or ne l'avons pas disposer
de ce temps prenons en acte nous nous
sommes contentés de tenter d'élargir le
nombre de communes concernées par ce
mode de scrutin
cependant il nous semble que dans les
communes de moins de 500 habitants ou
2000 comme le prévoit le texte une
première avancée serait que les listes
même incomplète qui se présentent soit
composée alternativement deux candidats
de chaque sexe
certes le mode de scrutin majoritaire
n'assurait pas pour autant l'élection de
femmes et d'hommes se met cependant
cette mesure permettrait une plus grande
lisibilité de cette volonté par était
reportée par notre constitution est
finalement favoriserait aux favoris
rahim fidh et nous l'espérons un plus
grand nombre d'élus avec eux
voilà le sens de cet amendement que nous
vous proposons d'adopter mercy cher
collègue monsieur le rapporteur avis
défavorable de la commission monsieur
ministre l'avis est défavorable parce
que je pense que il ya un problème de
cohérence si effectivement on avait
choisi cet objectif là sa supposée de
choisir un système qui soit un système à
la proportionnelle parce que sans
déclinait que le système de listes sans
décliner les difficultés concrètes de ce
à quoi vous tirez votre amendement je
pense qu'on essaye en fait c'est la
quadrature du cercle à la fois de garder
la liberté au niveau des petites
communes de candidature est à la fois
d'avoir les objectifs qui sont
normalement la priorité sur les scrutins
de liste donc on ne peut émettre un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre nous votons
donc sur l'amendement pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veut bien levé la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veuille bien levé la main l'amendement
n'est pas adopté nous en arrivons
l'article 17 bis
monsieur non eh bien nous votons sur
l'article 17 bis pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé la
main 17 bis
merci que ceux qui sont contre va bien
levé la main il est adopté un amendement
sur l'article 18 g non moment nous avons
un amendement qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
l'amendement 122 tombes l'amendement
198e tombe
la maman 170 se rectifier il tombe
également et nous en arrivons au 225 qui
est présenté il tombe et au pardon elle
oui oui et donc le 3 126 tombes
également le 148e rectifié bis
monsieur la mini
oui alors donc c'est cet amendement
belle fille suit aussi un précédent
amendement dont un article précédent un
amendement de coordination 1 par rapport
à ce qui avait été présent que je vais
présenter
précédemment la l'initiative de notre
collègue pierre bernard reymond
mais j'irai dans le cas où il y aura à
vivre avis défavorable de la commission
et du gouvernement je le retirerais or
merci
l'amendement 30 capte rectifié bis tombe
également et il tombe
le centquatre rectifié bis même chose
tombe elle 260,2 rectifié pareil tombe
également donc nous avons simplement le
148 ribis et non ils tombés tous il
tomber tous donc nous en arrivons au
vote sur l'article 18
je n'ai pas de demandes d'explications
de vote que ceux qui souhaitent
l'adopter veuille bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veuille
bien levé la main l'article est adoptée
article additionnel après l'article 18
le 263 tombe amendements sur l'article
19 et annexes
j'ai une demande de parole de monsieur
charon
excuse moi je président monsieur le
ministre sur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues l'histoire du droit de vote
est un chemin précieux de l'histoire de
notre pays et de notre démocratie
il est éclairé par un principe simple un
homme une voix si dans l'histoire la
mise en place cet idéal fut longue et
parfois douloureuses nous devrions
espérer qu'en 2012 50 ans après
l'instauration du suffrage universel
direct lors de l'élection du président
de la république et 67 ans après
l'accord du droit de vote aux femmes et
aux militaires nous soyons pas revenir
honoré au mieux ce fameux principe
pourtant si l'élection présidentielle
respectent effectivement le un homme une
voix
les élections locales sont soumises à la
loi de la carte électorale
il s'agit évidemment pas ton compte
est-il principe dans la mesure les
évolutions de population sont
inévitables et la mobilité une des
caractéristiques principales de la
société contemporaine cependant notre
rôle de législateur est bien de mesurer
ces évolutions et d'y apporter la
réponse la plus respectueuse du grand
principe qui régit la représentativité
de l'élu dans notre démocratie
malheureusement les ajustements de la
carte électorale n'ont pas toujours été
réalisés sans arrière pensée il est
d'ailleurs amusant de noter qu'une forme
de justice immanente a souvent punies la
main qui avait essayé de tendre le cou
aux électeurs un peu de silence mes
chers collègues s'il vous plaît si le
président ne le fait pas c'est à moi de
le faire
c'est aujourd'hui en tant que sénateur
et élus de paris que j'interviens sur
cet article qui modifie la clé de
répartition des élus parisiens au regard
des évolutions de population qu'ont
connu les différents arrondissements de
la capitale
depuis 30 ans le tableau fourni en page
67 du rapport est à cet égard tout à
fait clair et présente un certain nombre
de problèmes quant à l'équité des
variations proposées par ce projet de
loi en effet si la population a
globalement légèrement augmenté dans la
capitale nous constatons de fortes
disparités dans la répartition de cette
augmentation
la logique de la réforme de la
répartition des conseillers de paris
devrait donc visait à rétablir les
équilibres de représentation en ajustant
le nombre de sièges aux évolutions
constatées dès lors comment comprendre
par exemple que 17ème arrondissement se
voit priver d'un représentant alors que
sa population est stable à 0,6 pour cent
faisant passer à 14 mille le nombre
d'habitants par élus alors que dans le
même temps le 4e arrondissement qui a vu
chuter sa population de 10 7% garde ses
trois sièges ce qui équivaut à un ratio
de 9000 habitants pas réguler plus
généralement comment ne pas soupçonner
une autre logique que celle de l'équité
quand les trois conseillers de paris a
ajouté dans ce projet de loi l'ont été
dans des arrondissements majoritairement
à gauche et que les trois qui ont été
retirés l'ont été dans les
arrondissements majoritairement à droite
7e 16e 17e les 1er 2e et 3e et dans une
moindre mesure le 4e arrondissement
profite d'une sur représentation au
conseil de paris et ce à double titre
leur population prise en totalité a
fortement diminué en trente ans sans que
cela n'affecte pour autant le nombre de
conseillers de paris qui sont déjà et
seront élus après le projet peut-être
est-il temps de réfléchir à la question
du regroupement des quatre
arrondissements centraux au sein d'une
seule et même entité
pour l'heure le projet de loi ne règle
pas mais institutions lis un
déséquilibre qui existe depuis 30 ans et
qui conduit à ce que la voix d'un
électeur du centre d'un capital vaut
près du double de celle d'un électeur
parisien autre qu il apparaît dans le
tableau la fourchette se situe entre
5871 habitants par élus dans le 1er
arrondissement et 15000 69 pour le
cinquième soit plus de deux fois et
demie cette disparité qui compte plus
que les évolutions démographiques
elle même aurait pu être équilibré à
l'occasion de ce projet de loi bien au
contraire elle est aujourd'hui accentuée
dans les trois arrondissements concernés
par la suppression d'un siège
os conseil de paris en passant par
exemple pour le 7ème arrondissement
de onze à quatorze mille habitants
paraît lui il ne s'agit pas d'une
réforme mais bien d'une manipulation
visant à fausser la représentation les
électeurs des 7e 16e 17e arrondissement
au conseil de paris
la solution la plus équitable me semble
être celle proposée par l'amendement de
notre collègue yves pozzo di borgo dont
je suis costumes quennec cosignataires
pardon et qui consiste à définir à deux
le nombre de sièges au conseil de paris
pour les 1er 2e et 4e arrondissements et
a13
ceux du 16e et du 17e mais chaque
collègue
il est de notre devoir de législateurs
de veiller aux meilleures conditions
d'épanouissement de la démocratie et non
de l'aménager indignement pour truquer
ces équilibres je vous remercie
nassir collègues voilà pour l'examen de
la réforme électorale annoncée par
françois hollande lors des états
généraux de la démocratie territoriale
nous reviendrons bien évidemment dans
notre journal de 19 heures présenté par
michel grossiord très bonne après midi à
tous sur public sénat